stranger things too has officially
arrived and has introduced two new kids
to the Hawkins Indiana crew Billy and
Max are step-siblings who've moved from
California with their parents and
couldn't be more different from one
another Billy is a loose cannon who
behaves like a bully and desperately
wants to dethrone Steve as the coolest
kid in school meanwhile max is a
skateboarding tomboy who proves to be a
wizard at Dig Dug and catches the
attention of dustin and lucas just as
they prepare to face a new threat from
the upside down the actors portraying
the stranger things to do Eau de coeur
Montgomery and Sadie sink are still
relatively new to show business as well
but she still may recognize them from
some of these other productions the
comedy club not long before the release
of stranger things - Australian native
Dacre Montgomery's career started
gaining traction with a small role in
the 2016 Australian American horror
comedy better watch out a critically
acclaimed over-the-top film chock full
of teenage talent the film is basically
a deadlier version of home alone and
let's just say that Montgomery's
character gets in over his head
soon after Montgomery also starred as
Mike in a few less men a direct sequel
to the critically panned Australian
British comedy a few best men before
earning the role that would transform
his career altogether morphin time taker
Montgomery's biggest pre stranger things
role is unquestionably that of Red
Ranger Jason Scott the leader of the
titular superheroes in the Power Rangers
reboot although he earned the lead in
that pick he'd never seen the show or
films that started at all before
auditioning he told The Hollywood
Reporter I'd love to blame that I was on
the west coast of Australia in the most
isolated city on the planet but I think
Power Rangers really had reached every
corner of the earth so I don't know I
just missed it
even so he had no trouble adapting to
all the Mighty Morphin that went down on
the set and even delivered the film's
most iconic line
it's morphin time on Broadway
Sadie sink started acting professionally
at ten years old after an obsession with
2006 as High School Musical inspired her
to pursue drama in a rural Texas
community theater eventually she earned
the title role in the 2012 Broadway
revival of Annie which is when the ball
really started rolling on her young
career
it was also then that she first met
stranger things Caleb McLaughlin and
Gaytan Mata Rizzo who were starring in
the Lion King and lame is robbed at the
time as she told Vogue if you're a child
and you're on Broadway you automatically
know every other child in a production
it's a proper community there's a park
on 43rd Street where we would all go to
let off energy before we had to go back
and perform another show
though Annie was her biggest Broadway
gig Cink also starred alongside veteran
Helen Mirren in 2015's the audience TV
turn while hitting it big on Broadway
Cink made her television debut in 2013
as a guest star on FX's hit series the
Americans she later pop up in other hit
series such as Blue Bloods in the
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
of course sinc didn't merely make cameos
before landing the role of max on
stranger things second season the young
actress was notably featured as a main
cast member on the NBC thriller American
Odyssey breaking into the big screen
Sadie sink made her big screen debut in
2016 sports drama Chuck in which she
plays the title character's daughter
Kimberly the boxing biopic received
generally positive reviews and though
her role was minimal helped bolster the
young stars resume her most prominent
big-screen role to date is that of a
young Lori walls in the 2017 American
biographical drama the glass castle
based on Jeannette Walls his 2005 memoir
of the same name the film follows an
autobiographical account of the author's
poverty-stricken childhood existence
with her family and father while the
film has received mixed reviews it
certainly proved that sink is just as
much talent on a film set as she does on
a small screen series as stranger things
to escalates their public profile count
on de coeur Montgomery and Sadie sink to
continue accelerating their already
prolific screen careers thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to